[Music]
opposition Syrian National Army fighters
moved under cover of heavy artillery
shelling by Turkish troops the advanced
was Nayla the town was a rebel
stronghold until two weeks ago when
along with the city of Soraka it fell
into the hands of Syrian government
troops the UN says the offensive by the
Syrian army has resulted in the largest
displacement of civilians since the
start of the conflict nine years ago we
remain very alarmed about the safety and
protection of over 3 million civilians
in Italy and its surrounding areas in
the northwestern part of Syria as
reports of airstrikes and shelling
continue to take a heavy toll on the
civilian population in retaliation for
the death of two of its soldiers in an
attack blamed of the Syrian army
the Turkish Defense Ministry said dozens
of Syrian soldiers were killed and
military vehicles destroyed Turkish
officials warned of an imminent military
offensive if singing troops don't pull
out of the Demilitarized Zone and
although generally
Turkey is a sovereign and independent
state it takes its own decisions will
make necessary decisions and soldiers
will act accordingly we will establish
the ceasefire even if we have to use
force with the fighting showing no signs
of abating thousands of internally
displaced continue to converge in Eid
live city Alaska
I hope the Turkish backed operations
will deviate our sufferings because
that's the only way we can return to our
homes and our villages the international
community keep talking about peace but
we know we will only go back to our
villages if the Turks launched an
offensive turkey has expanded its
military presence in Italy following the
death of 13 of its soldiers in Italy
earlier this month officials here insist
their troops were deployed to establish
peace and provide humanitarian
assistance to the hundreds of thousands
of people who fled government military
campaigns it's too early to determine at
this stage whether the offensive by the
Turkish back
in an element serikov is part of a major
campaign to retake territory lost over
the last few months or just a limited
operation but since Turkey and Russia
have not agreed on how to implement a
ceasefire and push the Syrian army
behind the Demilitarized Zone fighting
is likely to continue
Hashima bar al Jazeera a tie